[Musique]
bon avec mon ex on n'est plus ensemble
mais voilà on continue à se parler on
s'envoie régulièrement des sms regarder
crève espèces d'ordures ta gâché deux
ans de ma vie façon je n'ai jamais aimé
et un smiley immeuble un vrai plaisir
je ne comprends pas les gens qui restent
amis avec leurs ex tu vas tout dire à
ton ex comme tu dirais tout un ami au
maintenant qu'on est juste amis je peux
être le dire c'était trop marrant
comment tu faisais mal l'amour excellent
mais d'ailleurs mon nouveau mec c'est un
dieu vivant au mit c'est comme si tout
ce que j'avais vécu avant on n'avait pas
existé tu vois ah oui je peux très bien
ça me fait trop plaisir qui se confie à
moi d'annoncer que je me sens vraiment
bien
c'est bête à dire mais moi franchement
ça me ferait trop chier que ma nouvelle
meuf soit plus complice avec son ex
qu'avec moi monsieur présente nico c'est
mon ex
mais tu peux aussi la fait pas tout ou
alors ou alors tu peux l'appeler essai c
c'est normal ton mec pas moche tu avais
une nouvelle meuf
j'aimerais paca soit pote avec son
ancien mec tu vas y à toujours forcément
une petite ambiguïté
donc ça c'est moi et justin au camping
là on était au ski à la montagne et là
on était à la mer c'est qu'il mec est
avec vous tout le temps face à son ex
ils sont passés super pote tu
t'inquiètes d'accord vous avoir bien pas
très grave en attendant mais leïla
sodomise quand même ouais mais c'est
amical les filles n'aiment pas trop
qu'on a connu dix mille ex avant elle
je peux comprendre même temps quand à
zéro expérience que t'as jamais rien
vécu jeu là c'est un peu moyen quand
même c'était forcément émotif pourra
rien en tout cas ça me fait plaisir
d'état première expérience
[Musique]
pasqua là bas mais rhône cellule c'est
la braderie qui se passe au québec ce
soir c'est ma soirée rien ses excuses
moi c'est juste dans ma tête moi quand
je suis en couple avec une meuf
ouais parce que je sois vraiment complet
qu'un mec je ressens qu'il avait
toujours tout savoir sur mes ex sur mon
passé pour avoir une relation
transparente et scènes - sauf que c'est
justement pas très sain quitte à coucher
mais carrément bakool et à bay à lui si
sarah mathilde à anaïs anaïs premiers
mois aussi voyager si j'ai pas envie de
savoir et benoît c'est un jour tu as
plein délire moi je trouve que toutes
les femmes sont belles mais j'avoue que
il ya certaines taxes à moi que j'assume
moins que d'autres je veux dire
j'aimerais pas forcément les croisés
avec des potes quoi ils savaient plus
quoi dire
normal ça fait long feu face à vannes un
salut josiane je pensais pas trop voir
un jour alors normal tu ne présente pas
et qui est 26e rect ouais une ex amie
n'est que sami ben on attendait quand
même sortis ensemble pour deux raisons
normal que des vannes alors elle
toujours dans l'humour la blague mais ce
n'est pas une blague à l'égard des
nouveaux de nombre d'écrans a fait voir
à merde merde il est tombé par terre je
suis vraiment maladroit
bon bah merci josiane on se voit une
prochaine fois on se rappelle baisse
peut pas dit mais bloquaient toujours
des blagues à elle toujours l'humour le
coluche
moi je déteste recroiser les nex avec
qui j'ai perdu contact c'est
l'impression d'une tonne sorte de
compétition chelou 2 2 qui est la
meilleure nouvelle vie et norman ça va
je te présente mon nouveau mec
salut à habas ouais bah moi c'est ma
nouvelle meuf ouais bah sauf que moi mon
mec il est hyper bien habillé avec moi
pareil super féminine très élégante
ouais bah bah moi il ya des gros muscles
web harel
voilà pas de musique mais bon alibert
sympa face à lui il a fait sciences po
lagrave de la culture et ben moi c'est
aussi plein de trucs de la culture elle
connaîtrait france connaît tous les
trucs président l on appelle point
commun c'est génial images l'équipe déjà
avec plaisir ouais ok je te refais un
café
vous êtes maintenant réfléchir volutes
au cours avec 1/2 sucre et une noisette
de les nuages délais un nuage de lait va
jamais je peux poser une question qu'est
ce que ça veut dire ce smiley immeuble
merci d'avoir regardé ma vidéo si vous
voulez venir me voir sur scène c'est
possible mon spectacle norman sur scène
continue cette fois ci dans tous les
zénith de france moi j'ai vraiment hâte
de vous voir en vrai pour une fois vous
serez pas que des vues ou des
commentaires ça qui est cool
donc si vous voulez prendre votre place
il ya un petit lien dans la description
merci à tous danke schön
mais liam normal ciao